imaginons que l'on souhaite construire
une construction verticale
autour d'un axe vertical qu'on appelle
rased
et cette construction est fait d'un
empilement de tranches successives qui
ont toutes la même forme à deux
dimensions
mais pas toutes la même taille pas
toutes le même diamètre et ce diamètre
qui peut varier avec l'altitude on le
notera à des deux aides donc des deux
aides c'est une fonction qui peut varier
avec l'altitude et qui représente la
taille des tranches successives de notre
bâtiment
la question qu'on va se poser c'est
quelle doit être la fonction des deux
aides pour que la pression subie par
chacune de ces tranches soit exactement
la même donc pour que la pression dans
le matériau qui constitue le bâtiment
soit constante à toutes les altitudes
pour résoudre ce problème il faut
commencer par calcul et donner une
expression de la pression que subit une
certaine tranche donc on va imaginer que
cette tranche est localisée à l'altitude
z
et on veut essayer de déterminer la
pression que subit cette tranche donc la
pression on l'a notre app et deux aides
c'est la pression subie par la tranche à
l'altitude z et la pression c'est égal à
la masse fois l'accélération de la
pesanteur
la masse ici représente toute la masse
qui est au dessus de notre tranche donc
on va appeler cette masse m2 aide m2
aide c'est une fonction qui du coup
décroît avec l'altitude puisque plus la
tranche est élevé moins on a de masse
qui se situe au dessus
ça c'est le poids ème fois j'ai la masse
multipliée par l'accélération de la
pesanteur nous donne le poids et la
pression c'est le rapport entre le poids
et la surface de la tranche donc on va
diviser sa part la surface de la tranche
qu'on va noter s deux aides
alors une première chose qu'on peut
faire ici c'est noté que si notre
tranche est un carré de côté des la
surface s2 aide peut être écrite comme
des au carré
on verra par la suite que le
raisonnement qu'ont fait fonctionne en
réalité avec n'importe quelle forme pas
forcément un carré il peut s'agir d'un
cercle où il peut s'agir de plusieurs
cercles par exemple ce qui compte c'est
que la forme reste la même à chaque
altitude dans chacune des tranches
bon et bien maintenant on à l'expression
de la pression en fonction de l'altitude
on voit que cette pression dépend de la
fonction m deux aides et donc on va
essayer d'exprimer cette fonction m deux
aides
alors la masse qui se trouve au dessus
de la tranche z
c'est simplement
l'intégrale c'est à dire la somme de
toutes les tranches qui se trouve au
dessus de z donc l'intégrale de z
jusqu'à l'infini on part de l'altitude
de notre tranche et on monte et on fait
la somme de toutes les masses de chacune
des tranches
de dm la masse infinitésimale d'une
tranche donc on voit qu'une tranche ici
on peut imaginer qu'elle a une toute
petite épaisseur qu on notera dz
et la masse d'une tranche c'est sa masse
volumique
alors on va réécrire l'intégrale ici la
masse d'une tranche c'est sa masse
volumique fois son volume c'est-à-dire
la mascc contient le matériau par unité
de volume multiplié par le volume de la
tranche donc la masse volumique on va là
notre héros et le volume de la tranche
c'est sa surface multipliée par son
épaisseur et la surface on a vu que
c'était s2 z ou encore des eaux car et
deux aides
x l'épaisseur qu'on a noté des aides
alors attention ici ce dessin n'est pas
le même qu'ici ici des deux aides c'est
cette fonction qui représente le
diamètre de nos tranche alors qu'ici dz
c'est l'élément infinitésimale selon
lequel on intègre qui représente
l'épaisseur d'une
d'une tranche infinitésimale mans petit
alors on voit ici qu'on a réussi à
exprimer la pression et deux aides en
fonction uniquement de la fonction des
deux aides puisque m2 zi6 dépens de
l'intégrale de des deux aides donc on
peut réécrire l'expression de
ppd de z est égal à g
/ des deux aides au carré
fois la masse de z la masse qui se situe
au dessus de la tranche et cette masse
on l'a exprimé ici avec cette intégrale
alors l'euro ici c'est une constante on
peut le sortir de l'intégrale
et voilà on a cette expression pour la
pression subie par une tranche à
l'altitude z à
l'heure à partir de ça on voit que
l'expression est un peu compliquée et en
particulier on aimerait nous trouver la
fonction des deux aides telles que cette
fonction ici paix soit constante alors
pour faire ça on va d'abord multiplier
de chaque côté par des cars et deux
aides de sorte à isoler l'intégrale
alors sur multiplient de chaque côté on
obtient des cars et deux aides x p et si
je vais arrêter de noter p2 aide je vais
voter uniquement paix puisqu'on veut
imposer que la pression soit constante
donc ce pays si c'est simplement un
nombre une constante
et ça c'était gallager foire os x cette
intégrale
alors ma on a cette expression on peut
remarquer que si on dérive de chaque
côté ici ça va nous annule et
l'intégrale en fait quand on dérive une
intégrale l'intégrale disparaît alors il
faut qu'on fasse attention à une petite
subtilité ici le z et en bas de
l'intégrale ça veut dire qu'on commence
à intégrer à partir de z jusqu'à
l'infini donc ce qu'on peut faire c'est
inversé nos bornes
donc commencé à intégrer depuis l'infini
jusqu'à z
mais alors quand on fait ça on intègre
dans le sens opposé et donc il faut
rajouter 1 - devant l'intégrale
bon et bien maintenant on peut dériver
chaque côté de l'équation alors la
dérivée du côté à gauche la dérive et de
2,2 des cars et les aident ces deux fois
des deux aides fois des primes z donc là
on dérive par rapport à z
x p qui est simplement une constante
alors pour faire cette dérive est ici on
a utilisé le fait que la dérive et 2e au
carré par rapport à eu c'est de u et
ensuite il faut multiplier par la dérive
et de l'ue par rapport à z si on veut
dérivés par rapport à z
et tout ça est égale à la dérive et du
côté droit de l'équation alors - géraud
c'est une constante on peut le laisser
et la dérive et de l'intégrale c'est
simplement ce qui se trouve dans
l'intégrale c'est à dire des cars et
deux aides
et là on se retrouve avec une équation
différentielle
que l'on va pouvoir résoudre alors une
première simplification qu'on peut faire
c'est remarquer que des deux aides se
trouvent des deux côtés donc on peut
diviser par des deux aides des deux
côtés
et puis pour simplifier la tâche on peut
diviser par 2 p et obtenir l'expression
de la dérive et 2d
qui vaut du coup moins jai ho / 2
pd2 aide
et donc là ce qu'on a trouvé c'est que
la fonction des sa dérivée s'est
elle-même
x une certaine constante un certains
nombres négatifs
alors ça si vous avez fait un peu des
équations différentielles vous savez
reconnaître la solution la fonction dont
la dérive et est elle-même c'est la
fonction exponentielle et cette
constante ici va être la constante de
multiplication deux aides dans l'expo
l'ancienne donc la solution de cette
équation différentielle
cédé 2 aide égale une certaine constante
qu on va noter des 0
x l'exponentielle de moins généraux sur
de paix la constante qui se trouvent ici
fois z
et ça c'est notre expression final c'est
la solution de notre problème
c'est le profil de diamètre de nos
surfaces
de sorte que la pression soit la même
sur chaque tranche
donc ça c'est l'axé z
et des deux aides c'était la taille de
chacune des tranches
donc ce qu'on observe ici c'est que le
profil des par rapport à z est un profil
en exponentiel décroissante c'est à dire
qu'on a une forme en fait de cette cette
allure là alors on peut la trace et de
chaque côté et on reconnaît la forme de
la tour eiffel est en fait cette
remarque n'est pas anodine la forme de
la tour eiffel a justement été calculée
sur ce principe là
de sorte à assurer que la pression reste
constante à chacun des étages de la tour
eiffel